carol can you thank you
he's on the right hey get down
folks guys guys down down down
come on thank you
can't hear either huh
[Music]
hello it's recording it's recording here
no it's recording yeah it's going to
thank thank you for letting me know well
first off thank you all for uh
thank you for coming out here today and
being willing to hear what i have to say
um i just want you to know that
for the press i i truly support freedom
and press
i think it's one of the things that
makes our country so great
and i really hope that you'll be able to
tell my story
a little bit better instead of just
reporting and repeating
uh maybe some things that you don't like
about me
or things that were on social media in
2018.
you see the reason why i ran for
congress is because
i really don't respect what our
government has become
as just an ordinary american someone
who's had to work hard all my life
someone who's been married for almost 25
years and raised three kids
and i gotta tell you my three kids are
the greatest part of my life
that's the best thing i've ever done is
to be a mom
i really love our country i love our
freedoms and i sincerely
want all of your children my children
and all of us to continue to have the
opportunity to have the american dream
but our government is failing us
you see we're approaching nearly 30
trillion dollars in debt
as a successful business owner for over
20 years if i ran my company
the way this government runs and spends
and waste and puts us in debt with our
own hard-earned tax dollars
i'd be out of business a long time ago
and we'd be homeless on the streets
but it's much worse than that for
decades now this government has sold
out our american worker sent our jobs
overseas to foreign countries
we've opened our borders wide open to be
flooded
with illegals coming into our country
think about kate steinle who was
murdered on a pier
in california she died in her father's
arms
krisha odette her father served our
country four
tours four tours in the middle east
protecting our freedoms when he came
back home his daughter
was killed by an illegal alien in texas
these are the things that shouldn't
happen
but these are the policies that are
allowed and continued
our country has made it legal
and funded with our tax dollars over 62
million abortions murdering god's
creation in the womb
that is a sin a disgusting evil
that is unfathomable i can't even
believe that it continues
but here's the thing all of these women
that have gone through that
it leaves a hole in their soul that
never heals
and those women have been taught that
this is the way that they should achieve
this is the way they can build a career
this is a way
that they can solve the problem that
they didn't want in the first place
that's a horrible lie it's a terrible
lie
as a mother and a woman who's had a
successful career
i can tell you being a mom is the
greatest gift of my life
i really hope that america can end the
evil of abortion
i also want you to know that free speech
matters
free speech really matters and yesterday
when the democrats
and 11 of my republican colleagues
decided to strip me of
my committee assignments education and
labor and the budget committee
you know what they did they actually
stripped my district
of their voice they stripped my voters
of having representation to work for
them
for the budget a successful business
owner that knows how to make a profit
not a loss that's what my district voted
for me for
i'm a mom with three kids
who has taken my children to gun free
school zones
their entire time they went to school
and when i was in 11th grade at 16 years
old when joe biden
created gun-free school zones one of my
schoolmates
brought three guns to school on a school
bus and a duffel bag
brought them into the school in the
first period class because he was very
upset
at two of his classmates he pulled out
his weapon
went to take control the coach in the
classroom
knocked him to the floor but he was able
to reach in and get another one of his
guns
fired his weapon took control of our
school and we were held hostage in our
classrooms for five hours
i want you to know i know that fear that
david hogg
felt it's terrifying it's terrifying
when the only person in the building
with a gun
is very upset and is there to do evil
and there's no good guy
with any guns to protect us that's why
when i was in washington i could go
from senate office to senate office just
like david hogg and say
vote no to gun control because we need
our second amendment rights
we need to be able to protect our
children with good guys with guns
just like the people up here protected
themselves
with 30 000 national guard troops
imagine that they want to leave our
children defenseless
but they will surround this place with a
big beautiful border wall
and a whole bunch of good guys with guns
see these are the policies that disgust
me
these are the policies that disgust the
american people
and these are the policies of hypocrites
you see when the people
in charge want to just spend your money
and spend your money and you have no
choice but to give it to them
and believe me i've been a good taxpayer
for years now and i always will be
and then they want to send our
hard-earned dollars over to foreign
nations
and so-called foreign aid to fund things
like border walls
and bridges in schools and roads
and abortion that's wrong
our tax dollars should stay here in
america our tax dollars should fund our
border wall
our bridges our schools our roads
they should help our homeless they
should help our people
our forgotten our orphans our foster
care children
that's what our hard-earned tax dollars
should be doing
not what these people here have been
doing for decades
the those that are in charge have been
here
for decades decades do you know the
average age of retirement
it's around 64 65 years old in the
private sector
but not here in congress they cling to
power
as long as they can because apparently
it's addictive and they can't give it up
this is something that i just can't
tolerate i can't take it and the
american people are so sick of it
you see a record number of americans
voted for president trump
record number of republicans voted for
president trump do you want to know why
it's because they loved his policies
they loved his fight
they loved the fact that for once we had
a president that stood up for america
stood up for american businesses and
remembered the forgotten
he was a president that didn't care
about your skin color
because god created us all equal and
thank god our constitution affirms that
he was a president that wanted every
single person to achieve
and that's why we supported him that's
why i've always supported him
and when i tell you republican voters
support him still
the party is his it doesn't belong to
anybody else
this impeachment trial that's going to
happen next week is a
circus it's a circus that allows media
companies to get lots of clicks
lots of views and sell ad dollars
and you know what that's pretty
disgusting too
everyone here knows that he did not
cause this attack on the capitol
nor did i nor did any republican but the
responsibility falls squarely
on those that invaded the capital the
ones that planned it ahead of time
those are the people that should be held
accountable
i was in the chamber unlike aoc
representative ocasio-cortez that faked
her
outrage with another hoax just another
hoax that gets shared everywhere
you see those kind of fake lies
like aoc representative corey bush
telling people that i attacked her when
in fact it was on video that she
attacked me
this is the kind of fake outrage that is
dividing our congress
along with the fake outrage on the news
every single day
that's dividing our people you know what
the media does and you guys are great at
it
and i'm telling you this because i want
to like you
but you're doing a really good job at
addicting our nation to hate
teaching people to hate people like me
president trump and then on the right
it's the same way
teaching people to hate aoc ilhan omar
nancy pelosi see it goes both ways
doesn't it
but teaching people to hate and
addicting them to it
is killing our country it's causing
people to no longer be friends
families to no longer talk to each other
even husband and wives getting divorced
parents not talking to their children
and the other way around
i think that's terrible and it's
shameful
when you have such a platform as you
have
what do you want your legacy to be do
you want your legacy to be the platform
that destroyed our nation and caused our
people to hate one another
or would you rather be a platform that
told the truth because you're given the
great gift
the freedom of press so that you can
tell the truth
i would love for you to be that platform
and i would be so proud of you
i wouldn't be mad at any of you i had
the greatest
opportunity yesterday and i'm so
grateful for it
i got to say what i had done wrong
and do you know how freeing that is i'm
not kidding
i seriously feel blessed by god because
i got to do it on a world stage
i got to say i said things wrong
i believe things that were wrong and you
know what you know i'm i'm so happy i
got to do that my district is thrilled
with me
people all over the country are thankful
in supporting me
and for that i'm grateful to them none
of us
are perfect and when when we go about
our life thinking that we are
we're such hypocrites truthfully we
really are if we think we're perfect we
can judge one another
that's such a mistake so
going forward i've been freed i do i
feel free
because you know what's happening on
these committees you see we have
a basically a tyrannically controlled
government right now
the democrats we've got joe biden
writing executive order after executive
order sign him sign him sign him
doing whatever he wants up there in the
white house
we have nancy pelosi leading the
democrats in congress
to do whatever they want they don't care
what republicans
have to say they don't care about what
our districts and our voters have to say
they only care about pushing their
socialist agenda through
they only care about taking away our
freedoms
that's not right so if i was on a
committee
i'd be wasting my time because my
conservative values wouldn't be heard
and neither would my districts right now
my republican colleagues
are being told that their white skin
makes them inherently racist
or that their service in the in our
nation's military to our country
defending our freedoms
makes them bad and a domestic terrorist
how are we at this place how have we
come here
the few bad actions of some do not
define the many
and that's the truth they kicked me off
of my committees
after spending a year promoting
supporting funding on act blue
blm defending
lying and calling these peaceful
protests when there's buildings burning
in the background
and sharing bail bond links to get the
criminals
out of jail but they want to kick me off
committees for
social media posts that were conspiracy
theories
that's pretty hypocritical you see the
american people won't forget
because they're still reeling from the
devastation of this past year
where cities were burned people were
attacked police officers still dealing
with it
attacked night after night they take
that home with them and it hurts their
families
occupying federal buildings taking over
police precincts
so much damage tearing down statues and
monuments erasing our history this is
what has happened
i do not condone what happened on
january 6th it was one of the scariest
days of my life
next to being held hostage in a gun-free
school zone when one of my stu one of my
fellow students
took it over with a gun and no one
protected us no one could
it was terrible
so i'm going to ask all of you think
about what you report
when you're on the news calling riot's
peaceful protest
the american people are disgusted with
you because you're lying
when you're promoting people that
protect these things and want to
continue it
people are sick of it they're fed up
because they lost their businesses
and they may have gotten hurt and
they're tired of being attacked because
they want to wear a red hat that says
make america great again
or they voted for trump and we're proud
of it
things have got to change and i tell you
again
i'm fine with being kicked off of my
committees because it'd be a waste of my
time
you know who i am i'm a very hard worker
and i'm proud of it
so now i have a lot of free time on my
hands
which means i can talk to a whole lot
more people
all over this country and i can talk to
more people and make connections
and build a huge amount of support
that i've already got started with
people that want to put
america first and don't care about the
party lines
and don't care about any of the
political identities involved
and that's something that i am very
excited about
so i look forward to going home and
seeing people in my district
i'm thankful and overwhelmed by their
support
i'm grateful that i had the opportunity
to say the things that i
don't believe and i shouldn't have said
in the first place
and i'm really grateful to my god
because
he forgives me and that's what being a
christian is all about
i have a message to other christians in
this country
don't be lukewarm that's not what your
faith is for
our savior died on a cross so your sins
can be forgiven and he doesn't want you
to be quiet about it
he wants you to share the gospel and
share it with everyone
that being said i'm going to let you
guys go about your day i know you got
many things
yeah i'll take some questions yeah i
just wanted to ask you specifically i
know you talked yesterday
i listened to your speech but you said
on a video in january 2019 i'm just
going to read it to you verbatim he said
it's
by our law representatives and senators
can be kicked out and no longer serve in
our government
and it's a crime punishable by death is
what treason is
what you say did you see my did you see
my speech yesterday
i how many how many stories did you
report on russian collusion conspiracy
lies
no i want to know have you apologized
for russian collision conspiracy lines
have you i don't have to i
stand by the fact that you said nancy
pelosi is guilty of treason
i think you heard my speech yesterday
you owe the people an apology you lied
about president trump
you owe the people an apology i've done
mine yesterday
okay next next question
think what do you see as your role here
going forward
my role is the job i got elected to do
um i'm going to vote very conservative
pro-life pro-second amendment pro-border
pro-america pro-american businesses
pro-economy pro jobs we need to reopen
this country
we need to put kids back in schools
keeping them at home is killing our
children
depression is high suicide's high we
canceled prom canceled graduation
cancelled their lives i'm going to be
working hard on those policies
and i'm going to be holding the
republican party accountable and pushing
them to the right
what do you say thank you jen pellegrino
you mentioned aoc and i wanted to ask
you about that you know
your supporters commonly know you as mtd
there's a lot of comparisons that could
be made as a freshman in congress making
waves
receiving positive and negative
attention on both sides of the aisle
would you say that perhaps you've maybe
scared democrats
in the media as well in the same way
that aoc when she stepped on the scene
that kind of made waves among
republicans
i'd say there's a comparison between us
and the fact that we really don't care
what other people think about us because
i can say that for myself i've never met
her but i assume she
probably feels that way um but there's a
major difference in us
aoc embraces policies of socialism to
what you could call communism
she wants to have she wants to have all
the power
and then the people that she claims she
wants to help her policies would reduce
them to poverty
and they wouldn't have many freedoms
left so there's a big difference
than us um i support our constitution
and all of our freedoms
and i'll work very hard against her
policies
what do you say to him and the other 10
republicans that voted against
uh or voted for removing you from the
committee well there were 10 that
that voted for impeachment against
president trump and they definitely paid
the price they heard from republican
voters
there were 11 that voted against me
yesterday um and that that's something
that our leaders should
be very upset about kevin mccarthy and
the rest of the republican party is
working hard on taking back the majority
and when you have republicans in the
ranks voting against one of their own
opening the door for democrats to go
after every single republican next
that that really is a big betrayal and
that could cost
us the majority in 22. people are very
angry that's all i've heard from people
all morning
furious about that so i hope that my
republican colleagues
really think about what they've done i'm
sure they're going to hear from their
voters at home because the base is loyal
to president trump
and the base has been very loyal to me
and they've shown me that
[Music]
my question is is there anything that
you haven't
said that you now want to say i'm sorry
for
not just you regret or walk back but is
there anything you are
sorry for saying in the past oh of
course i'm sorry for saying all those
things that are wrong
and offensive and and i sincerely mean
that and i'm i'm happy to say that i
think it's good to say
say when we've done something wrong so
yeah
are you sorry to david hogg what you
said to him
david hogg was an adult when i talked to
him i don't think any of you have
realized that david hogg
was working with the organization uh
that was
they were going around working hard for
strict gun control laws i'm very opposed
to those policies
and so being in the same situation as
david hogg my voice matters too
and so no i'm not sorry for telling him
he shouldn't push for gun control
what we need to do is we need to protect
our children i think you're expecting
we should protect our children and your
baby as well
um with good guys with guns and not
allow them to be sitting there sitting
ducks yeah
thank you you talked earlier about the
media teaching people to hate it wasn't
it you who liked
page on facebook of comments saying
nancy pelosi should get a bullet to the
head
and didn't you know this reminds me of
when you guys would ask president trump
president trump do you denounce white
supremacy and he would say
i denounce it and then you would ask him
again and he would have to say i
denounced
you know here's here's the thing when
you want to keep telling the same story
over and over but you don't want to tell
the truth that's your problem
and that's how we end press conferences
well